you are watching ColdFusion TV
hey guys welcome to another cold fusion
video so this is just a quick video to
let you guys know about some cool stuff
that's been in the works lately I'm
excited to tell you guys that I'm
partnering with TEDx Los Angeles on a
new initiative TEDx actually approached
me and gave me an opportunity to
spearhead a movement to drive action
towards a cause that I believe is making
a positive difference in our world the
unique thing here is instead of giving
money we're going to be driving change
directly through a nonprofit
organization the organization which I
chose to drive positive action through
is called movements org an online Human
Rights platform that connects those
without a voice in closed societies to
those in open societies who have the
skills to help and assist them movements
takes out the middleman in human rights
and create the link to strengthen the
voice of those who are oppressed and
weaken the power of oppressive dictators
if you'd like to join me in taking
action to help this organization you'll
be rewarded with access to some awesome
perks and prizes from me all you have to
do to join the pledge is click the link
below where you'll be taken to the
campaign's mobile web page your impact
will be measured verified and rewarded
in fact it's supporting action you
complete an engineer coin a currency
which you can use to redeem prizes and
perks from me here's why I find this
exciting normally if there was a
pressing situation or issue happening in
the world current social media methods
for attempting to help the situation
usually include liking giving a facebook
reaction or sharing but think about it
what does that actually do to help the
situation by using this system we can
actually quantify the amount of impact
generated and actually help people the
success of this campaign
will be presented and featured at TEDx
Los Angeles it will be used to showcase
how we can use our online presence to
incentivize our friends and community to
action specifically directed and
important causes and nonprofit
organizations and pretty happy to be
part of a potentially groundbreaking
effort to see how YouTube can create a
positive change in the world this goes
along with my belief that YouTube's
impact can be more than just videos it
has the potential to make an impact on
society in many ways which is one of the
pillars of this channel so click the
link below and take a look I'm excited
to see what we can do let's make this
huge gasp thanks and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video cold
fusion are you thinking
you